[Music]
hello everyone I'm torn or be from the
Android tools team this is Maggie from
the Android platform team and we're here
to introduce this cobbling talk because
we both use and love Colin and we're
super excited that it's now officially
supported by our team's yes so one of
the big reasons why we decided to adapt
cutting was you guys everybody here all
the developers were interesting Carson
in the application who have been asking
about Kathleen so we thought you know
usually these Cougars onstage at Google
i/o and we decided that this time around
we would have non-googlers so we have
Christine Ellie from Pinterest and
jporten some square so they are going to
do all the work and Tori and I will just
zip here enjoy
okay so hopefully all of you were in
hobbies presentation earlier today he
talked about the language and the
language features outside of Kotlin just
the language in general and today we're
going to go through examples in android
how the language features can be used to
basically clean up a bunch of sort of
rough edges of how you write Android
code so the first thing to start with is
you know here we have a boring main
activity and what's interesting to note
is that this parameter is actually
nullable so if your app process is
starting from scratch this is going to
be null and the way that we've now
represented this in Java is with noble
annotation support annotation and what's
great is that as these have been being
added to your code and sport library
code when you start writing Colin the
fact that the method that you're
overriding has that annotation means
that Kotlin indicates that it's a noble
type so all of the work that you've been
doing to annotate over the last few
years is now going to pay off in Kotlin
where the type system models null
ability
similarly in Android 4.1 a lot of work
was done to normalize the getters and
setters on all the views and if you saw
these are traditionally called beans in
the Java programming language and what's
nice is that Colin takes these and
collapses them into what's called
property so in Java you refer to them
directly but if we rewrite this in Colin
you'll see that we're referring to just
an alpha property and when we're reading
from edit calls together and when we're
writing to it it calls the setter so all
of that work that was done again now
pays off in Colin
okay so here's some sample code that
iterates there illustrates when you need
to perform some operation over the
children inside of the view group view
group is very similar to a collection
but it doesn't have any of the niceties
of collections like being able to use a
for each loop if we rewrite this in
Kotlin we get much more declarative
syntax the first thing to note is the
range here we're using that in fix
function and it actually will you know
even though it's a function it's so it's
like an intrinsic in the compiler so you
still get a for loop that uses indexes
in the bytecode and then here you can
see that the child count property that
we're calling again comes from the get
child count method which is in Java what
we can do we can do a lot better than
this right this isn't that much
different it's just a little bit more
clean how can we make viewgroup behave
more like other collections well you saw
the extension methods you can add an
extension method to view group which
does this iteration and then your
calling code becomes you know much more
like you would over a normal collection
the nice thing to note here is that
extension methods will be sugar into a
static method where the view group is
just the first parameter an important
thing to note is so this is a
higher-order function it takes in a
function as its parameter this will
actually cause an anonymous class to be
created at the call site that
encapsulates the code inside the lambda
so this can become prohibitively
expensive right if we're using all these
higher-order functions and creating all
these anonymous classes deck size goes
up method count goes up well we can
actually do is mark this as being an
inline function so this wasn't mentioned
by Hadi what it does is it basically
takes the implementation of this method
and in lines it in to the call site and
so because the code has been moved you
no longer have to create that anonymous
class and so this method essentially
becomes free so
use so one thing that you might have
missed is we actually lost the ability
to know what index of child we're
looking at but that's easily solved with
second extension method that allows the
index to be passed in and again it's an
inline function we have no additional
overhead here so that was for iteration
iterating on the child views but there's
a lot of other things we can do to view
group to make it behave a lot more like
a traditional collection so for example
if we add a get message as an extension
function we can now pull out child views
as if it was you know list or array we
can refer to them by index and have that
corresponding view returned key thing
here again that how do you pointed out
this is an operator function so it we're
declaring that it has a special call
sight syntax and that's what all of
these are going to be so how about
adding and removing views well we can
add - assign + + assign and so this
allows us to use you know a shorthand
syntax for removing and again adding
one more would be looking up to see if a
child's already in and again the
implementation of these functions we're
just reusing the methods that you
otherwise would have been calling but
getting a better syntax at the call site
which be hated which allows the view to
behave much more like a collection and
so this wasn't highlighted in haughty
stock but you know it kind of looks like
this is magical right when you're
looking at the code at the top where
you're using these operators how do you
know what implementation of that is
actually running well a cool trick in
IntelliJ and Android studio is that if
you actually put your cursor on one of
the operators you can command B into it
and will actually take you to the
corresponding function so even though
you get the nice call side syntax you
still have the visibility into what the
implementation is doing and if you want
you can actually call these methods as
if they are extension methods not using
the operator syntax because again
they're just normal functions so
extending a type isn't limited to just
methods we can also add properties and
so how about adding the number of
children as a size property which is
what a list or array would expose
interesting thing to note here again
using string interpolation also
mentioned in hoti stock okay
this one's a little more advanced but
having the for each function that we
added only allows us to do that type of
iteration where as a list we have all
these other higher-order functions
filtering mapping that we can use that
we can no longer use on view group
because you know it doesn't extend that
base type what this code does which you
don't have to like really look into and
understand is add the ability to create
an iterator of children and so now we
get access to using the traditional for
each loop and if we want we can use
those higher-order functions that exist
of that expire order extension functions
that exist on iterable so here I'm
collecting the height of all the visible
views very declarative and these if
they're inline functions you lose you
lose the overhead as well so extension
functions are great for encapsulating
repetitive tasks so if you're using
custom trace point because an example I
always forget to put the N section and
especially if you're refactoring code
that has trace voice in it it's very
easy to rearrange you know which n
section is applied to which begins
section and it ended up screwing up you
know the systrace output what we can do
is just go back and use this trick over
and over again we can encapsulate that
code inside of an inline function and so
and this will perform the beginning and
end and then it will execute our lambda
in the middle but as an inline function
we don't pay the cost of allocating
anything and so now our call site just
becomes trace with the tag and then
whatever is in the body is automatically
wrapped in begin and end
another nice thing is that you can
actually return from these functions and
so if you're computing something we
don't lose the ability to capture return
value okay so same tricks over and over
again a lot of times when you writing
the same boilerplate code you can get
this like tunnel vision where you lose
track of the ability to differentiate
whether something is correct or a
mistake because we're so used to seeing
it you just gloss over and so you might
have missed looking at this that we're
actually missing setting the transaction
to successful and so the Alva code and
this block wouldn't have even ran this
is another one where we can just apply
the same trick write an inline function
that encapsulates this this ceremony
around interacting with a database
transaction and then our call site
becomes extremely simple and declarative
this one is especially interesting
because we still have to refer to the
database inside the transaction block it
would be nice if we somehow could
associate the statements inside the
block with you know the enclosing
transaction because we already specified
it on the database so it's redundant to
say it over and over again one way to
accomplish this would be to change the
lambda that's being passed into the
function such that we inject the data to
the database reference back into it and
this allows our code to pass this into
the body this allows our codes are
referred to the it parameter which is
when there's a only a single argument
being passed the lambda you can just
refer to it as it this isn't as nice as
it could be though because now every
statement that we put inside this lambda
has to have it prefix in front of it so
just like we had extension functions
which add methods to a type we can
create extension lambdas or as I believe
cotton calls it lambdas with receivers
what's the same trick where if we change
the parameter of the lambda that's being
passed in to itself be an extension
function of the database
this means that the body inside the
lambda is going to execute as if it was
a method on legalized database and such
we can call methods without having to
qualify them with any reference so now
our call Sai only mentions the database
once and then we can just call the
methods for performing you know inserts
updates and deletes without having to
qualify them with this database
reference okay second with databases
doing you know inserts like this is not
terrible or deletes I guess in this case
but the problem is actually the database
that underlies that you know has to
execute this it has to parse the query
every single time you know figure out
that it's syntactically correct figured
out where the question marks are that it
needs to bind arguments into and so if
you're running this over and over and
over again you're basically wasting time
in the database for having it to parse
your query every single time the way
that this is solved in the sequel ATP is
is by compiling a statement ahead of
time and then reusing that over and over
again and so now the database only has
to parse this one and then it just kind
of remembers creates a model of what the
query is and then when you execute it
and only has to insert the arguments and
execute them so this is nice we get a
performance win if we're calling this a
bunch of times but we actually change
this such that if we were calling delete
by first name on the you know a
background thread before this compile
statement is going to run whenever this
class is created which is usually the
main thread and so we move database work
onto the main thread the weight if this
is fixed is with a feature called
delegation and this was property
delegation it's basically allowing you
to supply code behind a property that
can run whenever it's called whenever
it's assigned to or read from so in this
case what we're doing is we're
delegating the implementation of this
delete by first name property
and to a Kotlin built-in Kotlin feature
which is going to make it lazy so lazy
takes in a lambda now that only gets
called the first time that you get the
value from this property and so what
we've done is now allowed this to have
the same behavior as the original where
it was parsed on the background thread
but now it only does it once instead of
many times there's a lot of examples of
where delegation on properties can be
useful another built-in one is
observable which allows the lambda that
used to fly to be called every time the
property value is changed so I write a
new property to this name and if the
delegate calls this lambda with the old
value the new value for properties that
aren't immediately going to be
initialized that you know will very soon
be initialized instead of marking them
as nullable which requires you to
initialize it immediately when the class
is created you can use a delegate that
allows you to it's sort of defer setting
the value and so if you try to read from
this without setting a value it's going
to throw an exception but if you write
to it and then read from it totally fine
so this is perfect for cases like
activities and fragments where you don't
control the creation of the class but
there is a method in the lifecycle
that's very early where you usually set
up these properties and you can write
your own delegate delegates just the
interface that you can implement so we
have one which allows us to bind views
so it automatically if this is like in a
view subclass it will lazily look up
this view the first time that you access
it
another feature of delegation is class
delegation so the transitions framework
lacks a base class that you can extend
from such that you only have to override
one method wouldn't be nice if we
somehow could only override the method
we needed and then have have something
else that we delegated to for those
empty implementations well you can do
this you can create a class this is a
object class which is a singleton in
Kotlin and it has empty limitations of
all the functions and so now on our
original type what we can say is that
we're implementing transaction listener
but we're going to delegate every call
to the singleton type except for the
ones that we override and what Kotlin
will do is basically just add the
overrides in the class automatically
call the delegate for the ones you
haven't overwritten and your code that
is overwritten for the single method
will be used only for that one for
testing we abstract away espresso we
have these things called robots which
are just kind of high-level methods that
we can interact with instead of putting
espresso on every single test and what's
great is that the you know in Kotlin we
can call this in a very readable and
declarative way but again another trick
you can do is with these extension
functions and lambdas with receivers is
take that kind of weird-looking
constructor initialization and the apply
method which doesn't really make sense
in this case and turn it into something
that's much like a DSL and so you can
build these type safety ourselves out of
anything that you any like domain that
you have in your app the testing is just
of one example
and so finally field classes got to
mention as well so these are basically
type hierarchies that are that are
closed that other you know downstream
consumers can't add an implementation of
a great use of this on Android is for
recyclerview payloads so let's say
you're you're displaying tweets and you
know when you click them or when you
receive data from the web service you
want to update the counts and the icons
so we can write a steal class for each
of these events
which are the objects that we'll send to
recyclerview as payloads so that it
knows to only change a number or only
change an icon and here we're using data
classes again also mentioned and what's
great about this is we can use a lot of
the language features to make this
really readable on the consuming side we
get the nice looping with the lambda
then we can use the wind block which
allows us to do the smart casting so for
each of these branches they have
associated properties in the data
classes so each each one can now
reference the properties without having
to do the explicit cast because the Len
expression took care of it and so we add
the other branches and we get this nice
readable payload implementation instead
of what we have in Java which is you
know a bunch of objects and a bunch of
manual casting and so hopefully all
these examples have really really
resonated I mean there's so many things
over and over that we do in Java that we
can take the features of the Kotlin
programming language and apply them to
to make the code more fun to read and
more fun to write and so now I'm going
to turn it over to Kristina who will
talk to you about how you can adopt the
language in your organization
thank sake so hello I just want to start
out by saying we're here
this is IO 2017 and we have a session
about Kotlin a lot of people who made
that hop in there in the room both the
Googlers and the people from jetbrains I
know I appreciate it can we give them a
round of applause
all right so it's been journey not as
long as it could have been it's been
pretty Swift actually but it's been a
journey a lot of us have been out there
talking to people and evangelizing
Kotlin and at first there were some
objections like hey this language isn't
finalized are you sure we should use
that in production but as time went on
that was solved we now have our 1.0 and
we've had a lot of great releases since
then but I can guarantee that anybody
who's talked to anyone about Kotlin has
always filled it exactly the same
question and that was so what does
Google think about this and this is
great because of course now I could
stand here and say solved problem this
is my last slide goodbye but it's not
actually that easy because of course
this is like one of those situations
where your friend says hey do you want
to run and you're on the couch watching
TV and say sorry don't have running
shoes shucks
and then they say it's okay we can just
do push-ups you don't need equipment for
that we've taken away that first layer
of excuse it's the push back that we got
most often and and now we don't have
that push back we have a stance we know
where we stand but that doesn't mean
that there's no work to be done now
there's quite a bit of work actually and
so I'm going to talk to you about how to
do that a lot of the experience will
come from my mistakes but also from a
lot of you in the community that I've
been talking about into three steps the
first one and the easiest is you you
control what you say you control how you
say it and who you say it to that
control it gives you a lot of power the
second one is management this is often
the elephant in the room but we have
some strategies to make it easier to
talk to them and last and I leave it
last on purpose because I truly believe
it's the hardest part is getting buy-in
from your team and creating an
environment where
you introduce a new tool everybody that
you work with can be as successful and
as productive as you are with it so
let's start with you I have this quote
here that has absolutely nothing to do
with tech it's a very grandiose quote
and the essence of it is that the only
thing that's ever created change in the
world is a small group of people who
have cared deeply and I know that we're
not usually here to change the world
we're here to change code bases but the
reason I include this is because the
language of influence is applicable to
all of us
this happens in industries all around
the world and we don't get to escape
from it I know that a lot of people in
this room are saying but wait I'm an
introvert I don't know if I can go
onstage and do a dance and shout go
Kotlin and I'm not asking you to do that
there are a lot of ways for you to show
enthusiasm and to be passionate you can
tweet about it you can send a slack
message to your best friend an email and
SMS and MMS if we want to go back ten
years
it doesn't really matter there are a lot
of ways that you can communicate that
you care but the important thing is that
you do communicate because of course if
you're sitting here waiting for the
people in your office to be struck by a
thunderbolt and suddenly understand the
uninspiring nature of nullable types
you're probably going to be left waiting
so be enthusiastic and share that
enthusiasm with other people no matter
what that looks like but the corollary
to that is that the easy part is being
enthusiastic it's a great language it's
not that hard to get excited about it
but you also need to sign up for what
comes with that which is that people
will have questions if you have a build
system completely based on the Java
programming language and you introduce a
new tool to it there's a good chance
that it might pick up that something
might not go exactly as planned and you
need to be there to make sure that you
can fix that because if you care enough
to introduce a new tool
you also need to care enough to be a
steward for it that's all I'm going to
say about you because again it's the
part that you control it's the easy part
right just get excited it works now
management management is the elephant in
the room
I started by saying hey the number one
question I got was what is Google stance
but of course the number two thing that
I talked about with the community was
I'm sold
I love it but I can't convince the
people in my company that I should be
allowed to adopt Kotlin so let's talk
about that I have been on stage and I've
said hey there's this magic argument you
can use you just walk into someone's
office and then you say give me this
language and I'll give you an NP e or
relatively NP e
free app I say relatively because where
there's a will there's a way
but this is a great argument the more I
talked about it with you in the
community though the more I realize that
it boils down to something much more
fundamental and that is that Kotlin and
languages like it they help us offload
things that were not that good at on to
our computer and we already do this a
lot the way I know that we do this is
that we all collectively freak out
anytime our computer breaks I know I do
it I've seen other people do it and
that's because computers are
fundamentally a huge part of our life
they're really really good at doing the
things that we're really really bad at
and that frees us up to do some of the
more creative thinking the architecting
the making sure that it works for your
coworkers all of these more creative and
critical thinking tasks are things that
we get to focus on more and when talking
to management this is something that
they understand they're going to have
questions yes but if you move this
conversation on to the pain of hey I
have this tool and I want to use it more
effectively people understand what that
means
so of course one example of this from
Jake is just saying that types are form
of testing
and whether you fully agree with this or
not the underlying sentiment is that we
are catching errors sooner and we're
doing it without having to keep it all
logged into our head and since we don't
have to juggle the ten different places
that something could be null or mutating
or any of those other variables it gives
us more time to think about other stuff
so sorry this is my favorite photo in
this slide deck the point here is that
people and companies are risk-averse and
the reason they're risk-averse is
because someone's job out there is to
make sure that your company doesn't burn
down and that's a very noble profession
and I appreciate that they're there so
they have to keep us in check and that
means that when you're communicating to
them you can by all means feel free to
say there's this thing called Val and
then you change one letter and it's a
bar and it's magical and it's
revolutionary and you're going to love
it and if your manager is really cool
maybe they'll understand that but for a
lot of people that's not going to be a
really persuasive argument and it's
because even if they understand that
from a technical level it doesn't have
resonance so talk to people in a
language that they understand
talk to them not about the methodology
but about the end goal which is to say
instead of saying there's types no
ability say I can provide you an app
that's more stable for our users it'll
crash less the users will be happier or
if your management like mine values
moving fast say hey I have a tool and if
you allow me to use it I can make more
reusable code and I can iterate faster
and we can get more product out the door
again feel free to talk to them about
Kotlin I am never going to discourage
anybody from doing that but also step
out of your shoes and into theirs and
talk to them out of business level about
what they care about okay last and
hardest the team
now this is a really good place for me
to add the caveat that I'm here because
I've made some mistakes and I want to
share them with you so that you don't
have to make the same ones I'm sure
people will find new ones to make but at
least they won't be mine
so to start define success know what
that looks like for you and I say this
because I was out on the grass when we
announced that Kotlin was going to be
supported and I heard a lot of you
saying hey cool so does this mean that I
can just convert my whole codebase -
Kotlin and I said oh yes I mean if that
works at your office by all means but
what I've learned in my Kotlin adoption
was that if you do that you're going to
have to put up with grumbling for months
to come and and the reason for that is
that teams they're made of diverse
people and diverse people almost never
agree unanimously which is to say if
you're going to start up with two people
maybe you can go to lunch and agree on
this and push the code that day but if
you're in a bigger company and you have
30 or 40 devs on a team getting them all
into a single room and agreeing on
something is going to be time-consuming
and it's going to take effort and so
when defining success I would again
encourage you to focus on the outcome if
you want to stand there and say Kotlin
is the best language you can but I
guarantee someone will stand up and want
to argue with you because it's fun to
argue and developers love to do that
I'm one of them I know so what I would
encourage you to do instead is say we
want a stable codebase we want to hit
this metric for a number of crash grief
sessions we want to be able to iterate
faster any of these things it's easy for
people to agree on they're not
controversial statements and if you
start with a common goal with your team
then when you say hey there's this tool
it'll get us to this goal in XYZ steps
it's a lot easier to have that
conversations you don't have to start a
flame war you can sit there and you can
dissect pieces and have productive
conversations on smaller chunks now part
of this is also getting stakeholders on
board which is something I mildly did
but also mildly didn't so the importance
of this is that if you're like me and
you're a developer and not in the
management chain it means that if
anything goes wrong after you adopt a
new tool like Kotlin someone above you
in that chain is going to be on the hook
for it which is great for me but less so
for them so there's also this dynamic -
that consists of you standing here
saying hey this is a great language and
then someone going off and saying hey
have you heard about this language
christina says it was great but I just
wanted to hear your opinion and for both
of these reasons you want to make sure
that the culture setters in your company
are onboard both because if something
happens you want them to have your back
and to say this is the right path for us
it's worth it to push through this let's
just fix it and also because if the
culture setter is in your company aren't
on board you're going to have a lot of
dissent and I know we can get complacent
because the Interop is so good between
the java programming language and Kotlin
but it's really not a great place for
your team to be oh there we go
now also find someone who reviews your
code like this exactly like this I do
this for my team I've been known to skip
around my desk it's happened us any of
my co-workers in the audience and you
should find someone in your company who
feels exactly the same way and the
reason I say that is that again in
talking to the audience and into members
of the Kotlin community a lot of you had
said I just not Kotlin in and it was
great and nobody knew now 1 do you also
have jobs like how is that working for
you
I mean we need to talk I don't know
about these rogue commits that are just
coming up left and right I appreciate
the spirit though and and too that means
that you shoulder all that work on
yourself and I don't know about you but
I'm already pretty busy I got a lot of
emails to write during the day and so if
you can find people who feel like you to
work with that's going to make your job
less hard and the other reason this is
important is that this language although
it's been around for several years now
is just hitting widespread adoption and
what that means from your perspective is
that we don't have 20 years worth of
code styles to fall back on and best
practices and books and all of the
things of that nature and that means
that when you introduce Kotlin into your
code base you get to have those
conversations and as a developer that's
fun but it's also time away from your
work and what does this look like it
looks like you adding Kotlin to your
code and having almost you know two ways
to do almost exactly the same thing we
need to standardize our code base
ergo what is my company's position which
one do we default to I've also heard
from the Trello team that they have a
lot of conversations about what it means
to be null when we have types no ability
this wasn't a conversation that we had
to have before because by default most
things were knowable but now that we
control that in a much more concise way
what does it mean you need to decide is
it valid for me to make this thing
knowable or is that just completely
illogical for the data structure that
I'm building these conversations they
need to be had and while you can have
them with your whole team you can dive
in and say we're all on board it's going
to get noisy there's a lot of crashing
involved in deciding what your future
looks like and so this is why I would
recommend finding a nucleus and working
with them it should go without saying
that I also hope that you document all
of this
because at some point you should bring
everybody else on board and of course
I'm not saying not to get opinions I'm
just saying that if you try to adopt by
consensus it might not move you along as
fast as you would otherwise hope now I
also want to point out something this is
from Dan Lou's blog about what you're
expecting from your co-workers when you
ask them to adopt a new language and and
that's that you're asking them to go
from a place of expertise to a place
where they're new again and and yes
JetBrains has done everything in their
power to make this seamless the IDE
support is great you can copy and paste
or convert you can right click convert
you can have hints in your IDE you have
the compile time errors they have smooth
the way for you and it is easy way
easier than anything else I've adopted
but that doesn't mean that there's no
work and so people when they use the
Java programming language are often
coming from a place of having used it
for years and that means that they know
all of the little tricks they've read
all the interview books they've read the
blog posts and the puzzlers and all of
those things and so they know those tiny
little edge cases just from having been
in the environment for ages and when you
come to a new language you don't
necessarily bring that knowledge with
you a lot of it is still applicable but
you also have to expect that there going
to be some times where you you haven't
found all of the edge cases and you're
going to be burned by them and so if
you're asking that of your teammates you
need to make sure that onboarding is the
first-class citizen and I know this
isn't that exciting we're all developers
we want to code who wants documentation
anyways but it really really is
important if you want Kotlin to be
successful in your company and that's
because you can say oh well everybody on
my team right now they know Kotlin so we
don't need to on board but what about
when your interns come in or when you
hire someone new in two months we are
not at a point in the industry right now
where we can expect that everybody
walking through
our interview pipeline knows this
language and so if you throw them in the
deep end without any flotation device
that's on you and you should expect them
to feel lost and overwhelmed so make
onboarding a first-class citizen think
about it early this probably means that
you have to change what you're doing in
the first two weeks that your employees
arrive you'll have to update
documentation code examples make sure
that they have the tools they need to
run this new language and probably do
some mentorship as they learn the
language on the job do that work it's
really important and I know because I
put it off so don't be like me get it
out of the way early so that you don't
have a bifurcated team again inter up it
has it has all of the merits right it's
great but it can also make us lazy
because we can say they don't need to
use cotton they can use Java but Kotlin
it's here to stay and we want people to
enjoy it and we want them to partake so
just saying
hyoni Kotlin you can use Java it's not
the best route really now last my only
last remaining point show up be there
for the work that needs to take place
that documentation updating that
advocacy we all know Jake's white paper
from several years ago that didn't just
poof into existence he sat down and he
wrote it and I know at my company we've
had those moments too we've done the
behind the scenes work that has made the
adoption during the work day much more
successful and it's not glamorous I know
but if you want Kotlin to be successful
in your company it's necessary and now
that I've bummed you all out and told
you how hard this is all going to be I
just want to remind you where we are we
have official support for Kotlin and
that's a great place to be so yes
there's work involved in it I know and
it's not sexy work either it's not as
fun as writing Kotlin but it's worth it
we have the chance to use an amazing
language
so let's put the work in to make it
happen now I know a lot of you after the
keynote we're asking hey I'm interested
I'm sold how do I get started well here
are a few resources predictably I have
linked to both the Android documentation
and the jetbrains documentation on that
JetBrains site you'll find Cowen's which
are ways to go through coding exercises
and explore the language incrementally
as well as the standard documentation
and a repple and then obviously there's
a book that came out about Kotlin
recently and i would encourage you to
read it that's all I have for you today
there's no time for questions but we'll
be outside after this presentation thank
you thank you for joining this session
[Music]